next my doctor um when i approached her
again to ask for this exemption
she again reiterated no i can't there's
too many legalities around it
um i said can you see though my concern
considering the mandates have just come
in
i can't legally work
the wait time is anywhere from now 11
months to two years
um i don't know i i really i i feel like
i'm just stuck in this limbo world now i
don't know what to do
um
and she had even said to me
if i were to request her vaccinate me
she would say no because of my
anaphylaxis and that it was too risky to
do it in her practice
now
you haven't told me that before
i mean
yeah this is this is
it's kafka ask
right a doctor who knows that she can't
afford to vaccinate you
right i mean at least she has the good
sense not to do that
perhaps for the wrong reason but a
doctor who knows that that your medical
condition does not
allow her to responsibly vaccinate you
cannot write you an exemption that says
it would be irresponsible to vaccinate
this person i i just don't even i don't
understand
i mean really at some level you've just
discovered
a system
in which
all discretion has been removed
and i have to imagine that what's going
on
is that there is such antipathy
for people like myself
who
fear that there are things about these
vaccines
that may put anyone in jeopardy that the
desire to prevent folks like us
from finding an exemption has caused
them to remove exemptions from the map
and they're literally putting you in
danger of your life
in order not to grant an exception to
someone else and that
no
no rational system could possibly
function that way it's really
you know they have they have decided to
sabotage their own system because of
their anger at a certain
class of person and
uh i must tell you i mean you and i
obviously aren't in the same system
since i'm american and and you're
australian but
um
to the extent
that
my concerns which i think are legitimate
uh are
causing them to break a system
that that now can't protect you i feel
some responsibility for it
i i do and you know
i don't feel that it would be safe uh to
get the vaccine but certainly i would
probably get away with it i'm in a far
better position to do it than you
um and i i hate that we're being pitted
against each other like this
what what kind of crazy world have we
landed in
it's literally since all this um
i after after hearing that from my
doctor um
she said she would try again
for the
public system
saying you know urgent
this is vaccine related to see if it
could
progress me in the queue to be seen um
i was quite emotional from all this i
just was not expecting any of this to
happen
i
i posted a video on instagram to my
tiny little audience that i have
um essentially just being like
this is my story and
i don't know what to do it doesn't seem
to make any sense to me
um i was screaming out into the ether um
and
to my surprise the story blew up it went
viral overnight i had
i had a mix of reactions i actually had
a lot of people in the same boat as me
contact me because of this
and then i also had
some people in society saying well not
being aware of that this was going on to
people like me they were shocked to find
out that the people that
supposedly are the ones that they're
getting vaccinated for as the propaganda
is saying
aren't getting granted exemptions or
getting put through the ringer with this
um
however there were some in society
saying to me
anaphylaxis isn't that bad why don't you
just go get the vaccine
i would i i hope
that the people who said that you don't
know anything about anaphylaxis because
the idea that this is something that
because there's a checkbox of what
you're supposed to do when somebody has
an anaphylactic reaction that it's
something that we can just budget for is
obvious nonsense
i mean
not only
not only
is the anaphylactic reaction
a lethal hazard to you and the treatment
for it not a safe treatment and a
treatment that can fail
but it is also the case that the
vaccines themselves their very nature
causes them to reprogram elements of
your immune system you're obviously
somebody with an unusual physiology that
creates unusual jeopardy for you
encountering
things in the world
you are the last person who can afford
to have your immune system reprogrammed
in some unpredictable way that might
cause you to become allergic to new
things things that today you don't have
to worry about but a week from today you
might
there is no justification and
i mean i
i will also say
this isn't smallpox
covet is a serious disease but it is not
a disease that kills
healthy people
very regularly and therefore the benefit
that comes from vaccinating a single
person
like you is probably
near zero
the chances that anyone will be
protected especially in a place like
australia that has a low rate of covet
to begin with the chances that any
benefit comes to anyone from doing this
to you is
very very low
and
the risk of harm to you is not only
very high but the harm itself is likely
very extreme
yes
so
every single parameter of your story is
clear
they're all clear there's no reason
your if you wanted to test the system to
see
if it could grant an exemption you would
be the perfect case you just check every
box
and see if you get an exemption and if
you don't that says there are no
exemptions
yes
right that's that's a frightening
condition
it is and since all of this there
um
i guess since i i made my story public
and the video going viral
it was also picked up by a local um
australian
uh broadcasting news station which gave
me air time to discuss this
who again very similarly similarly to
you
um said that this is very clear
clear-cut i am the perfect case to be
granted an exemption
um
but prior to that after seeing my gp as
well i was
then contacted by an organization
which i was never referred to
they're called the victorian specialist
immunization services
as far as i can see they have actually
taken over the immunology clinic at my
treating hospital
i was contacted by one of their nurses
who asked me
who diagnosed me with the polyethylene
glycol allergy and i actually said to
her well your hospital did
and she said oh well i haven't looked
into your file
and she said well let's see how we can
get you in here to vaccinate you safely
which concerned me because i was like
well
there wouldn't be a way i'm
diagnosed anaphylactic
what i'm seeking is an exemption and she
turned to me and said oh no we don't
give exemptions
this is this is a a person working in a
hospital in a hospital yeah who
actually made the argument that you
should come in have the vaccination
and
if and when you have your reaction they
can treat you with the epinephrine right
then and there that's correct
i mean
obviously it's better than sending you
home but
wow how does how does a medical
professional
fail to understand the jeopardy that
they're putting you to
yeah yeah and i think this is where like
risk versus benefit has completely gone
out the window because it's
it's like i will i know i have
anaphylactic reactions to these
excipients um any time i've ingested one
put it on my skin i've always had some
type of reaction the severity
um
could be somewhat more mild at times or
somewhat more
severe
um
however it's a life risk uh we know that
anaphylaxis is
not a a small
a a low a low risk issue it is quite
high it can cause death
um and quickly
as well
um
so to be told that i was just compl that
just spun me out even more
um
and i and yeah i was really just
i had no idea where to go
and so i took it to social media with my
video
and then in like this bizarre twist of
fate um someone
although i never mentioned the name of
my doctor um
someone had seen my video
and this is my uh clinical immunologist
the private one that i was told the uh
wait would be 11 months to see um
got me into a
cancellation spot with him
in the next four days
so
if i never made that video at my wit's
end
if it never went viral
this would never have happened
i
i saw him
i gave him all my documentation
all of the correspondents from my
treating hospital who said that they
didn't look into my file or didn't know
about the polyethylene glycol being
recorded at their hospital i had all
that correspondence i took it with him
my gp also has all this correspondence
um and he literally said to me this is
clear cut you cannot receive these
vaccinations
the possibility of you also you you have
the documented polyethylene glycol
allergy
there's no point in skin prick testing
me for this because i've actually had an
i actually had an anaphylactic reaction
from skin prick testing before which
ended up resulting in me having
epinephrine administered
at my treating hospital from the
polyethylene glycol component
um he said there is no point testing you
for this not to mention also
the issue with skin prick testing is it
can be completely different
when something is injected into your
system
um at a concentrated level as well
your body can react differently so he he
mentioned all this to me and he said the
heart there is a huge potentiality that
the poly i will react to polysorbate 80.
um and given that i have had an
anaphylactic reaction induced by skin
prick testing i
i'm
[Music]
i'm sort of
it could react quite badly with me just
even getting the testing done for this
so he um
he actually filed that evening my imo
one one certificate to the australian
immunization registrar
ticking all the boxes for my permanent
exemption saying that i cannot get these
vaccinations
um
that was lodged three weeks ago
and i still have not received my
exemption
when i have oh sorry no i'm not going to
ask you the obvious question do you have
any idea what's happened
i've called the australian immunisation
registrar which are an arm of our
medicare which is
federally run
so this is now out of the hand of the
state government
um
i have called three representatives for
this
um to find out what is going on each
time i've been told a different story
uh the first time i was told that she
could see my exemption in the queue this
was last week
and that they were backlogged however
they were up today
they were up to the date of october 20th
to process mine was submitted on october
26th so it shouldn't take too much
longer
still hadn't received anything
yesterday i phoned them again in the
morning
they actually stated to me that they
got the exemption however it was
illegible to read
so they requested that my doctor send a
new one which was then received on
november the second
and i'm being placed back in the queue
now wait a minute
i mean
i think i'm fairly good at spotting
[ __ ] and i think i i may have
spotted a a healthy dose of [ __ ]
here because
this suggests the fact that there is a
cue and that yes well we can see yours
in it and we are working our way towards
it suggests that exemptions are being
granted
now if exemptions are being granted
what the hell have you encountered
wha why are you having such trouble
getting the system to recognize the
obvious need for you to have one or are
they just telling you that exemptions
are being granted as a stalling tactic
so once they go through this process
although your doctor may write the
exemption
it doesn't mean that you're granted it
the government can still deny it
right but
again betty look either there's a
discretionary process somewhere where
some human being gets to put an eyeball
on an application and say you know what
this one's just clear-cut let's grant
the exemption or there isn't a process
and the point is well there really
aren't any exemptions but we can't very
well say that can we
and i can't
it would seem if there is an actual
process of exemptions
then
you shouldn't have faced any of this
and if there's no process of exemptions
then what are they telling you
right that it's in a queue i mean maybe
maybe you've nailed it maybe the idea is
oh yes we haven't gotten around to
rejecting your exemption yet we've still
got many ahead of you that need to be
rejected maybe that's what they're
saying
i mean it's really you know it's it's a
it's a customer service nightmare is
what you're facing um where
something doesn't want to give you
something you're entitled to and so it's
going to come up with every excuse
and
um
without words
yeah it's been um the the phrase
conversations i had yesterday especially
hearing that it was requested that my
doctor sent a legible copy considering
the first representative that i spoke to
read to me that she could read
my exemption she saw it she read out
what was on it so
that sounded like it was legible to me i
was confused when this second
representative said that it was
illegible
so i contacted my private doctor again
who said no there was no
request for a second form to be sent
so they told you that they had requested
a legible one because the one they got
was illegible and the person
to whom they would have made that
request had not gotten a request
yes
well that does sound like what would
happen if they were bullshitting yes it
does
it does it seems to unravel a lot of
this um
yeah this this messy ball of twine that
has now been put in front of me yeah
so
i rang them again um
and i got another representative
who said that now i had
they could see that i had two forms so
one that was submitted on the 26 and one
that was submitted on the second
now i was like i'm very confused because
my doctor has said that they haven't
sent a second they actually asked me
would they like me would they want me to
send one
so i said to this representative i'm
very confused why do you have two
documents and who are they from
and he looked at both and said to me
they're from the same doctor i said well
how do you have two when my doctor
hasn't
sent a second i said unless it was
because my doctor had faxed one
and sent one by mail at the same time
and he said that could be the reason i
said well then why did this
representative earlier tell me that a
second one had been requested because
the first was illegible it seems like a
made-up story now
and i said so what's going to be getting
processed
and he literally said he didn't know
he did not know if my and i said well
i'm told that the one on the 26
because also the earlier representative
told me now that they're up to the 29th
of october so clearly my one on the 26
didn't get
approved
so now i must wait for my set one on the
second of november to be approved
yet when i spoke to this third
representative he said oh no we're not
up to the 29th we're only up to the 26th
it's
it's
it's unbearable it's
unbearable where did the humans go
you're obviously dealing with some kind
of
human looking
human sounding
drone
i i can't
there's
i
i wish i knew what to say i really have
the sense that even in a very broken and
this is this has been my experience even
in a very broken system
there is generally somebody
who upon seeing a story like yours
would know the way to make it work out
right somebody would recognize the
necessity the importance here and
somebody
for whatever reason because basic human
decency would say ah you need to file a
form
22-7
38 b
right and you've got to send it to this
office and not that office and then they
can send back a such and such and yet
you've clearly
you've
made enough inquiries you've been to
enough places you've talked to enough
people
that there just doesn't seem to be
anyone who can
who can staunch the bleeding
[Music]